hey everyone Cali here with a very early  look at code vain and upcoming action  RPG from the creator of God Eater it  takes place in a world populated by  vampires who of course have to feed on  human blood to survive and those who  don't get enough blood turn into  monsters called lost here you can see  our first look at some combat against  those monsters the lost retain the  weapons they used when they were  vampires which they then used to attack  you compared to God Eater the combat  seemed slower and requires more evasion  and strategy stay tuned to gain spot for  more news and gameplay on code veins  which is set for a 2018 release  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]